اخبار الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه من تلي
ابيب ايجاز اهلا بكم في اليوم الثالث من
الهدنه الانسانيه المؤقته اسرائيل تتسلم
قائمه الاسرى المقرر الافراج عنهم ومصلحه
سجونها تعلنوا الاستعداد لتنفيذ الدفعه
الثالثه كتائب القسام تنعي عددا من ابرز
قادتها وعلى راسهم احمد الغندور عضو
المجلس العسكري قائد لواء شمال قطاع غزه
وكل من القاده وائل رجب ورافت سلمان وايمن
صيام الرصاص الاسرائيلي يواصل جني الارواح
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه شهيد وثمانيه
مصابين بنيران الاحتلال في قطاع غزه وسته
شهداء في جنين واثنان في شرقي البيري
وجنوبي نابلس ونادي الاسير يعلن ارتفاع
عدد المعتقلين في الضفه الى
32 منذ بدء
الحرب مشاهد صادمه تتكشف مع بدء الهدنه
حجم الدمار على مد البصر في مدينه غزه
وشمال القطع والهلال الاحمر يطالب بمعدات
لرفع الانقاد للبحث عن المفقودين والحكومه
بغزه تقول ان الاحتلال القى 40 ال طن من
المتفجرات خلال الحرب ورئيس بلديه غزه
يؤكد للجزيره عدم وصول كميات كافيه من
الوقود ويقول ان المعاناه على
اشدها وزيره الدوله التعاون الدولي
بالخارجيه القطريه لولا الخاطر تقول خلال
زيارتها التفقديه لغزه ان وتيره المساعدات
لغزه لا تفي بالاحتياجات وتضيف انه لاول
مره منذ بدء العدوان الاسرائيلي تصل
المساعدات الى المناطق الشماليه بالقطاع
مشيره الى ان قطر مستعده لارسال ايه كميات
مطلوبه من المساعدات وان هناك عملا
ومحادثات في اتجاه محاوله تمديد الهدنه
الى اللقاء
n